[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Lynn is
uh going to start this hour off in
Philadelphia hi Lyn welcome to the
Ramsey
Show hey guys it's such an honor to
speak to you thanks for taking my call
sure what's up uh I actually have a
two-part question um not sure if I can
get to both of them but my first
question um is really starting to
something's really starting to get to me
it's an affecting my family and my
marriage um my husband is taking
responsibility um for his parents my
in-laws
finances he's has created them a budget
he's paying their bills for them he's um
going as far as controlling their
expenses uh I'm not sure this is healthy
and it's causing friction is he using
their money or your money he's using
their money okay so it's not costing you
anything how old are they how old are
they um they are in their late 70s okay
and why is this not healthy do they need
help um let's just say that them doing
it on their own they haven't been doing
very well
themselves um and I think my husband is
just afraid of you know them
overspending and
yeah but you you said that you said this
is not healthy and it's driving you
crazy so why is it not me crazy why is
it not healthy and why is it driving you
crazy I don't think it's healthy because
he's taking over and doing it himself um
we don't agree with it so he's causing
friction with us um and it's not that
they're not able to do it it's kind of
like he wants to do it for them because
because he thinks he'll do it better
could it be that he knows for 79 years
I've watched my parents fail at this and
they're getting really close to falling
off a financial cliff that as my as
their son I'm going to feel some sort of
obligation to help out with and I can I
can stop them from driving off the edge
is it that it is uh 100% that which I'm
okay with but he's kind of gone a little
too far not just giving them advice but
just BAS Bally there's something else
deeper why don't you do you not like
them I love them they are my second
parents I lost my parents at a young age
when we just uh we've been married for
25 years so they've become my second
parents um so what's what's the thorn in
your side on
this you know I think it's
that I I think you know partly it's that
they can't do it themselves okay and so
are you mad at them or him for that
that I think I'm mad at them okay so
let's make sure the anger in the right
direction all right
and and
I probably part of me is just kind of
bombed that the time that we should be
spending together on our own finances is
kind of going toward them all right
that's a totally different
conversation one of those conversations
gets wrapped up and you're and you
pressing your husband up against a wall
saying it's me or them and he's looking
and saying I love you both I dedicated
my life to you I said I do to you you're
my wife and I'm watching my parents
sliding off the
edge the real question you're asking is
I'm really frustrated that two grown
people who I love haven't and won't and
can't seem to figure out how to take
care of their money and my husband is
the kind of man who steps in that Gap
but I don't want that to come at the
expense of our marriage and our relation
relationship and our time together
planning for our future and so husband
can we spend time together focusing on
our finances that's separate then you
shouldn't be doing that with them you
see what I'm saying I do one of those
makes him have to wall up and pick and
the other says is makes calls is a
challenge are you going to be are you
going to be um my partner in this deal
and are you going to continue to dream
with me on what our house looks like so
you voiced to him that you're
frustrated I have he knows I'm he knows
I'm not a fan of the whole situation
okay so I let me tell you what I think I
heard you say and if I was wrong tell me
okay okay I think I heard you say I'm
frustrated because these two grown-ups
won't be grown-ups I love them but I
hate
irresponsibility and I hate the way that
they are just so lame when they don't
have to be and that aggravates me and
I'm also aggravated because you're
taking time away from us that I really
need to have some things done over here
on our finances before you go over
there uh you pretty much nailed it okay
why don't you say that back to him that
way I I think that's a really good idea
and can I throw one twist in there
that's gonna be hard for you to say
sure can you say I am proud that you're
the kind
of man that um sees his mom and dad in
need and however frustrating it is
you're willing to step that
get yes that's super important I do
agree you are proud of his character you
just you just hate it that they're being
so lame Mo and I gotta tell you I kind
of agree with you yeah it's super
frustrating I'm aggravated at both of
them they're perfectly able-bodied and
able-minded to do this and they're just
too trifling to do it right you're yeah
yeah and that aggravates that aggravates
people that are
responsible right and you know that
that's I I agree with your aggravation
um I just don't think that uh your
aggravation is going to fix
it yeah because you're not you're being
aggravated is not going to make them
suddenly
responsible correct and so they're
either going to run in the ditch as John
said or over the edge as John said um or
your husband's probably going to do what
he's doing because you know they may
have seven years they might have 10 and
um you know and they're either going to
be a burden to you all financially
because they completely wreck the rest
of their lives here or your husband's
going to do this cuz they the chances of
these people changing their habits the
old dog new tricks at this stage
probably pretty low is that fair yes and
can he go too far can he say hey I'm
going to help y'all not fall off the
edge and suddenly become their mommy and
daddy all in one yes yeah and it's okay
to call call that out call him out on
that yeah but yeah sounds like you got a
good man stuck in a weird situation and
it's frustrating frustrating let's work
towards the solution you have a valid
frustration with their irres
responsibility but not a good
solution he's got a better solution this
is the Ramsey Show